jetzt stell dir mal vor du hast ja ein
brain machine Interface mit einer
riskanten Operation einpflanzen lassen
um z.B Computer und Prothesen
anzusteuern aber nach wenigen Jahren ist
es im Körper verrostet das ist die
Herausforderung vor der nuraling steht
denn das feuchtsalzige milieö im Körper
wirkt stark korrodierend laut Tests
könnte ein nuraling Implantat 8 Jahre
funktionsfähig bleiben aber diese
Prognose basiert auf Laborbedingungen
unter denen Korrosion theoretisch
viermal so schnell stattfindet wie im
Körper die Realität könnte anders
aussehen in einem Versuchstier soll Ihr
Implantat seit fast zwei Jahren
funktionieren aber wie oft das
implantierte N1 schon versagt hat
darüber hält nurlink sich bedeckt und
jetzt